VICTOR O'LAUGHLEN: Hi, everyone.
Victor O'Laughlen
and Sarthak Pattanaik
representing Bank of New
York Mellon's clearance
and collateral
management business.
We're excited to present what
we've learned from our journey
in helping solve a key financial
services challenge that
has the potential to
bring big-time benefits
to our clients and the US
treasury market as a whole,
all realized by leveraging
Google Cloud's powerful data
science platform.
As the global digital
business leader
for clearance and
collateral management,
leveraging data through
analytics and machine learning
is a key focus area
for our business
in order to enhance our
ability to improve the client
experience.
Whether it's predicting
a failed transaction
or offering a prescriptive
analytics solution
to resolve it, our
future is firmly
planted in operating as
a data first company.
SARTHAK PATTANAIK: BNY
Mellon has a long history
of serving our clients.
As a CIO of clearance
and collateral,
my responsibility is to focus
on growing this business.
But it is important for
us to know how we got here
and how the business grew
to where it is today.
It will share the importance
of this exciting new service
that we are building.
VICTOR O'LAUGHLEN:
It actually starts
with the average investor
who, for example, saves
into a 401(k).
If the investor rebalances
her 401(k) account,
shifting from equities
in favor of bonds,
then her 401(k) administrator
may get those bonds
by contacting their
trading desk, who
in turn goes to the
bond market and says,
I'd like to buy treasury bond
ABC for 95% of the face value.
Buyer and seller, named
EB, make their offers,
and a trade is arranged.
The buyer and seller agree
to swap the bond for cash.
And they notify a third
party service provider
of the agreement
because they want
that service provider to manage
the actual exchange of bond
for cash at the end of the day.
The fund admin will
agree to many such trades
throughout the day.
In most cases that exchange
is successfully completed,
but sometimes it's not.
A counterparty may
not be able to deliver
the bond due to some
unforeseen event
occurring after the agreement.
But the investor still
needs their bond.
The fund admin keeps
some extra on hand
to make the investor whole
in case of a settlement fail.
But how many extra
should the admin keep?
Well, that depends on how often
a settlement failure occurs.
If the admin knew
that, they could right
size their stockpile and
free up valuable cash.
This cash could improve market
liquidity by buying and selling
more bonds or fund the
development of new services
for the investor.
So predicting
settlement fails is key,
but that would require a
total view of the market.
The fund admin
doesn't have that,
but the clearing and
settlement service does.
BNY Mellon is that clearing
and settlement service.
Because we're in the
center of the market,
we have a total market view.
And with that view plus Google
Cloud's powerful analytics,
we can predict which
trades will fail
to settle, allowing
the admin to predict
how many spare treasuries
to keep on hand.
Of course, BNY Mellon didn't
begin in the cloud era.
We had a 236 year head start.
In 1784, we were founded by
then US treasurer Alexander
Hamilton.
Some of you may have
seen the musical.
In 1789, the first loan
brought to the US government
was provided by BNYM in the
form of a treasury security.
Fast forward to
today, and treasuries
are the largest and most liquid
fixed market in the world,
with BNY Mellon still deeply
involved in this market,
clearing and settling
over $9 trillion in Fed
eligible securities a day.
Because of our important role
in the financial markets,
a core mission of
our business is
to invest in
resiliency and value
added services that help create
efficiency and stability.
And helping solve the
Fed eligible securities
fails challenge is a
prime example of that.
So we kicked off of
an investigation,
or what we call "formed
a hypothesis," into how
we might help predict
these settlement fails.
The fails vary from day to day.
But generally, they
amount to 1% to 2%
of approximately $4.5 trillion
in security deliveries.
This percentage seems like
a small number, and it is.
But due to the sheer
size of this market,
it amounts to
approximately $70 billion
of settlement fails a day.
Transactions that
do not successfully
settle by 3:00 PM
Eastern Standard Time
each day are considered fails.
So we aim to predict the
fails at 1:15 PM each day,
providing approximately
two hours notice.
Sarthak, can you tell us
how we went about this?
SARTHAK PATTANAIK: There are
four stages to our machine
learning process.
Stage one is focused on
data ingestion, where
we build a data
pipeline to move data
from our on-prem
transactional system,
to our on-prem data [INAUDIBLE]
all the way to Google Cloud
storage.
In the second stage, we are
focused on data preparation.
The first part of it is ensuring
good data quality controls.
And the second part of it
is feature engineering.
In the feature
engineering step, we
start off with
transactional information,
things like account,
security information,
and transactional information.
And then we iterate across
a multifunctional group,
try to get more information from
the clients, from the business,
from products, from developers,
as well as from the data
engineers.
At the end of
multiple iterations,
we lined it up
with 51 variables.
44 of them, we have
something that we identified
as part of those iterations.
And most of these variables
were economic in nature, things
like demand supply variables,
liquidity variables,
and transaction
velocity variables.
The third stage is
around model building.
And when we are
building the model,
we were targeting three
objective functions--
one, accuracy, second,
performance, and third,
interpretability.
And we evaluated
a whole plethora
of models from
simple regression,
to three base models, all
the way to neural net.
As we [INAUDIBLE]
over the models,
we did finally settle
with the light GBM model.
And the reason for that is
the balance between accuracy
and interpretability.
Our clients were very
interested to use a model which
provides them
directionality as to why
a transaction has a
higher chance of failure
than another transaction.
The fourth stage is building
the production pipeline.
Once we built a model
which would train and test,
having an automation to take the
output of the model, the output
coefficients into a
production system,
and ensuring that
that is seamless,
was critical for our success.
Also important was the frequency
as we retrained the model
every three months, and
also going through the model
validation to ensure
that the model did
what it's supposed to do.
What did we learn from
this entire process?
Three things-- first
is data culture.
We are trying to
transform ourselves
from a transaction-based
organization
to a data-driven organization.
And if you think
about data, we think
about the five Vs, which is
volume, velocity, variety,
veracity, and value.
Veracity was the most
important concept for us
because we wanted to build
is solid data control process
and solid quality
controls upfront.
The second thing we learned
was around our transactional
systems and storing everything.
Traditional transaction
systems, we focused a lot
on storing our inputs.
And then we have our algorithms.
And we stored the
outputs, which is
used for client
reporting, our end
of the regulatory reporting.
But as a part of
this process, we
tried to store information
at every point in time
during the algorithm
for every decision
point the algorithm took.
As a result, we captured
inordinate amount
of risk, credit usage,
inventory, position,
and cash information because we
do not know which of this data
is going to be useful
for our next experiment.
Thirdly, we realized
very quickly
that the success
of this project has
to be a mix of expertise
from the data engineers,
as well as the subject
matter experts.
As we were iterating,
there are a couple
of sprints where we
had 95% plus accuracy.
And when we went back
and looked at it,
we actually found that we
are predicting the past.
So that was an
interesting thing,
that when your model
is significantly good,
go back and check your model.
The second thing in this
entire process that we learned
was the concept of agility.
This is a multifunctional team.
And the goal of the team was
to have small experiments
in a piecemeal fashion and have
a hypothesis for each of them.
And as we addressed, as
we hit those hypotheses,
we moved forward, or we go back
and restart with our new set
of sets of hypotheses.
So for that to happen,
it is important
that infrastructure
is not [INAUDIBLE],,
and infrastructure is
an enabler for that.
And the third thing
that we learned
is digital transformation.
This is not about technology.
It's about people, process,
and technology together.
When we build machine
learning projects,
those are not deterministic.
These are exploratory.
These do not have a
requirements document, a design,
a development, and a testing
process like a waterfall.
You have to think about
small experiments.
You have to look at hypotheses.
And you have to iterate.
So fast iteration is
key to our success.
Now let's talk about results.
Our target was to predict 40%
of the fails with 80% precision.
And happy to say that we are
able to hit those objectives.
Now, I'll hand it over to
Victor to talk about what's
next in the service.
VICTOR O'LAUGHLEN:
Thanks, Sarthak.
So next is a client trial.
After approximately a year
of development and testing,
we are now currently
in the process
of trialing this service
with our key clients.
This includes interacting
with the service
in a production-like
environment and evaluating
the benefits of the
service so that they
can trust that the service
is accurate and consistent.
As the client provides
feedback to us,
we can seek out opportunities
to make client-specific model
optimizations.
Are there specific
operational nuances
about that particular
client that
are required in order for
us, and from a modeling
perspective, in order for us to
refine the precision or recall?
In addition, we will
continue iterating
on improving the service
through various market cycles.
For example, in our
line of business,
month ends, quarter
ends, year ends
are important times
for our clients.
And the dynamics
of trading change,
therefore making it
more difficult for us
to predict settlement fails.
But by identifying
these different cycles,
adjusting for the
different training periods,
and looking at different
model variables,
we can find opportunities
to improve the model
during those time periods.
And finally, as we
predict outcomes,
we can then identify
opportunities
to have prescriptive
analytics integrated
into those predictions to
help mitigate the fails, which
will then allow for our
clients to get more value out
of this service.
Now finally, we'll
hand it over to Sarthak
to talk about, why Google Cloud?
SARTHAK PATTANAIK:
Why Google Cloud?
So first, I want to
talk about, why cloud?
If you think about
this project, the two
focus areas where around
scalability and agility,
the ability for us to run
complex machine learning models
requiring high
infrastructure requirements.
And if we had to
do it on-prem, it
would have taken us significant
time, as well as it would not
have been cost efficient.
So cloud was a natural
solution for this project.
Why Google Cloud?
There are a couple
of reasons here.
One is Google BigQuery.
BigQuery is highly scalable
and extremely performant.
Our developers and
business analysts
used to run queries on our
on-prem databases of two
to three days of
transaction data.
On Google Cloud
BigQuery, they were
able to run the same
set of queries over two
to three years at a
transaction level.
And the performance was
very similar to two to three
days on-prem.
The second thing was
about collaboration.
This was a perfect opportunity
for the Google engineers
and the BNY Mellon
engineers to work together.
Both of us focused on data.
How do we build
strong data practices
in terms of data ingestion,
data storage, data indexing,
as well as delivering
data to our clients?
It was fascinating to watch
both the teams come together
and solve a business problem.
Thank you for watching
this, and hope this
was helpful for yourselves.